Vi volevo raccontare di quella volta in cui mi
sono incrinata una costola perché ho tossito
- Ma incrinato vuol dire che si... - Si piegano, cioè non sono rotte però insomma, sono danneggiate
- "Aug" - Beh non "Aug", tipo "Aauuuggg"
- Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata
di Vita Buttata, il tema della puntata di
oggi è "Modi stupidi in cui mi sono fatto
male"
"Vivi per miracolo"
"Morti per poco vivi"
L'idea per questo tema mi è venuta un paio di settimane fa mentre ascoltavo rds, ora non ricordo chi
aveva tirato un tema simile fuori e i
messaggi erano stati molto carini, quindi
ho pensato di replicare questa idea qui
sul canale, quindi shutout rds grazie
mille, ma per ottava si importante ho pensato
di invitare all'interno degli studios de casa mia una persona che cerco di
tenere lontano il più possibile in
realtà dalla mia dimora ma che purtroppo
ogni tanto invito più per diciamo un
ritorno personale che per un piacere di
passare del tempo con lei, sto parlando
della mia compagna di banco nonché...
"Mia compagnia di bianco sembra che c'ho ancora 16 anni - Beh ormai so passati venti anni (Vega)
- Va bene, colei che mi ha fatto passare
la maturità, stella polare ma in
generale stella di vita, Vega. Non so che c***o ho detto lo sai?
- Rieccoci qui - Allora sei pronta? Io poi mi
sono ricordato che pure tu hai avuto un
modo stupido in cui ti sei fatta male
- Io ne ho avuti vari, ma...così in apertura?
- No perché...dopo me lo sono ricordato perché ho detto "Sicuramente lei
tirerà fuori degli aneddoti di me da
ragazzo quando ero stupito e inguardabile
e sciocco - Beh su questo tema che eri stupido e
inguardabile...A parte che già è emerso
chiaramente nella presentazione - Non so è un periodo in ci non riesco a parlare, ed è un periodo che
va avanti da una trentina d'anni - Chiamiamo uno
specializza - "Dolori bizzarri" Allora iniziamo a sentire
- Che è l'unico che non hai detto comunque - "Dolori bizzarri"
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, ti racconto di quando avevo 16 anni, avevo la prima fidanzata
Quel giorno stavo male, avevo la diarrea. Allora ho preso
l'enterogermina. Rocordo che c'era un (?) dentro al parco della città, ad un certo punto
mentre stavamo assieme io mi metto sopra l'altalena, l'altalena si rompe, io cado col c**o a terra
il dolore pazzesco! E dalla forte paura mi sono c****o addosso
Quella ragazza non l'ho sentita più e so scappato - Strano! - Nooo
Ma era l'appuntamento? - Stranissimo è andato tutto così bene!
Mi chiedo come mai lei non l'abbia
richiamato subito. Avrà tipo cancellato
il numero, buttato il telefono
Io avevo per un momento in realtà l'ansia che, andando in altalena, tipo
la forza centrifuga avesse fatto tipo effetto, hai presente, il raggio...cresta...esatto la Sirenetta
♬ Si avvereràààà ♬
- Io ho due episodi da raccontarvi, uno è
stato impigliarmi il labbro superiore
nelle bacchette dell'ombrello.
L'altro episodio è successo che per
farmi dare i soldi dai miei genitori no?
Quella cosa del topino dei denti, mi sono
spaccato, mi sono spaccato un dente su un angolino del muro di casa
praticamente - Ma cioè sbatteva... Ma questa è la versione casalinga delle truffe delle assicurazioni
- Continuavo a sbatterlo fino a quando
non cadeva, non è mai caduto questo dente
Mi si è soltanto storto e io non ho
visto un soldo - Il dentista ne avrà visti... - Tantissimi
Questa è una storia un po' agrodolce...Qusti non sono "Modi ridicoli", sono tipo "discutibili"
Anch'io ce l'ho una volta in cui mi sono fatta
male in un modo assurdo ed è quando ho iniziato
a guidare il motorino, gentile pubblico sono caduta da ferma, e io ero
incastrata sotto il motorino, quindi non
potevo dissimulare e fuggire come avrei
voluto, e non aveva avuto nessun valore
e non sapevo come spiegare che ero solo cretina
- Ma ti è scivolato? Ma era bagnato? - No, non era niente, era che non lo sapevo guidare - No non lo sapevi tenere
- Ma io me lo ricordo. Ma tu non m'avevi detto
che c'era tipo del brecciolino? O stavi
cercando - Diciamo che sono caduta, mo le circostanze non era importante specificarle
- Ero a scuola, frequentavo le scuole medie e per quel giorno era stato prevista
un'esercitazione antincendio. C'era stato
spiegato che al suonare della campanella
avremmo dovuto nasconderci sotto i
banchi. In seguito, trascorsi un 5 minuti
uscire in fila per due dall'aula fino a raggiungere il cortile della scuola. Bene, nel
momento in cui la campanella suona, io
faccio per nascondermi sotto il banco
e mi do una ginocchiata sul naso, causandomi una violenta epistassi ed è stato quello il momento
in cui ho realizzato che
se veramente ci fosse stato un incendio
probabilmente io sarei morta - Per cause sue. Io mi ricordo che una volta da piccolino mi sono fatto male
da solo ma cioè,  il mio ricordo è difficile da
piazzare nel contesto della realtà e
della possibilità - Ti sei fatto malissimo quindi! - Sisi        - Hai dimenticato tutto - No. Ero piccolo, avrò avuto...
- Prego vada avanti - C'era una fiamma ossidrica, io l'ho
toccata - Casualmente c'era una fiamma ossidrica
- Però io me lo ricordo - Comunque eri in un ambiente molto sicuro per un bambino - Era casa mia!
- Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, parto col dirti che
ogni giorno combatto contro me stessa
per non farmi del male. Ti racconto di
quella volta che d'estate
mio padre mi portava sempre la colazione
e me la lasciava fuori dalla porta sulla
maniglia, così un giorno continuai
ad aprire la porta per prendere
la colazione e non so come vado a
incastrarmi il mignolo del piede sotto
la porta blindata. Cerco in tutti modi di scastrarlo
trascino il piede ma l'unico modo per scastrarlo era tirare il piede, così ho tirato
ho urlato talmente forte che penso che i
vicini pensassero che qualcuno stesse
sgozzando un maiale - Aspetta no... - Che cosa è successo?! Ci stanno troppe cose che non capisco
- Si però ci sono una serie di cose, tipo, primo, come fa a poggiare la colazione sulla maniglia?
Tipo il padre già non le rendeva le cose facili. Secondo, si è inastrata il mignolo
sotto la parta che è tipo così - Allora io ho un idea, la colazione era in sacchetto
Ma poi scusami, ma lei ha una porta della
camera che è una porta blindata?
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, volevo rendervi partecipi di
quella volta in cui, quando avevo dieci
anni, ho creduto fosse una buona idea
mettermi in piedi su una sedia, legarmi
la caviglia ad una corda che a sua volta era legata ad un albero e lanciarmi dalla sedia come
Tarzan. Il risultato però non è stato dei
migliori, visto che sono finita appesa
all'albero a testa in giù - Quanto era alta questa sedia? Fai l'albero...e questa è
una sedia. Se io salgo sopra, mi lego la
caviglia all'albero, e saltò giù, io casco
di lato con un piede in su - Qualcuno tirava la corda forse, cioè tipo
l'ha tirata dall'altro lato e l'ha appesa. Poi Tarzan non si legava le caviglie, ti do sto spoiler
- C'erano tanti modi per renderla
un'esperienza piacevole, sei riuscita a
trovarne uno dei pochi... - Piacevole non lo so Gu
- Vabbè se facevi un cappio...nono
- Certo seguiamo Guglielmo, facciamo un cappio - No facevi tipo un cerchio che non si
chiude, com'è che si chiama? Infilavi solamente la punta del piede, e tu potevi appendere...esatto e ti dondolavi
- Si no non lo fate - Io sono quella che fa a botte con un bicchiere e si trova
sette punti su una mano. Soprattutto mi do le porte in faccia da sola e non sono gli altri
altri, anche nei negozi prendo in pieno le
porte di vetro come per dire "No ragazzi
sto testando il vetro quanto è duro eh! Occhiolino insomma". Sono quella che tipo
con uno starnuto in metro dal naso esce scene splatter tipo alla Tarantino, e poi non parliamo delle testate
le testate sono il mio master, sia con le macchine quando entro che con i muri
- Mi fai venire voglia di conoscerti - Esatto...Non ho capito perchè
prendeva a pugni il bicchiere - Oh l'avrà guardata male, il vetro della (?), il vetro del bicchiere
è la sua kryptonite, lei deve distruggere tutto quello che è di vetro
- Ero in macchina con mia madre, ero
seduta accanto a lei, dietro c'era anche
una mia amica. Dato che la mia macchina a
quei tempi aveva l'impianto a gas e io
non so perché da piccola ero completamente
terrorizzata dall'idea che una macchina
potesse scoppiare. Ho iniziato a sentire
questa puzza di gas
incredibile e ho cercato di avvertire
mia madre e di dirle che ci devevamo
fermare. Però mia madre non mi ha dato
ascolto, quindi ho pensato bene, mentre la
macchina era in moto, di aprire lo
sportello e di lanciarmi letteralmente fuori
dalla macchina. Mi sono fatta malissimo,
nessun danno grave per fortuna, e inutile
dire che ... - Mia mamma è esplosa, però dai, tutto bene quel che finisce bene. Non so se capita anche a te
io sento pusa di... - "Pusa" - Pusa di gaz...puzza di gas un sacco di volte
Non ti capita mai di andare in un corridoio e sentire la pus... - La "pusa"...
E niente oggi c'ha un problema - Sono romagnolo
- Comunque aspetta me ne sono ricordata un'altra, una volta che sono caduta mi sono fatta
malissimo ed era portando le lastre all'ospedale
Stavo andando al policlinico a portare le
lastre al ginocchio al reumatologo peraltro
e sono scivolata perché pioveva. Sono arrivata lì zoppicando che la lastra nel
frattempo era peggiorata -. "Signorina dobbiamo rifarne un'altra" - Mi sono rialzata subito
ma in realtà mi ero fatta malissimo, tipo
ho corso, attraverso la strada, ho girato
l'angolo, mi sono tipo appoggiata al muro perché stavo svenendo dal dolore
- Quindi hai avuto il tuo momento dove dietro l'angolo sei crollata un pochino
come un'attrice quando ritorna dietro le quinte
- Ciao Gu, i modi in cui io di solito (*rumore di qualcosa che cade*)...eh vabbè!
Mi faccio male sempre allo stesso modo ed è...stupido, cioè sto sul  mio letto
sto reggendo il cellulare tenendolo
a pancia in su sopra la testa e a un certo punto il
cellulare mi cade e mi finisce
nell'occhio - Amica sei una di noi - Sei una
di tutti, cioè ragazzi succede a tutti - Che poi hanno inventato quelle specie di
anellini per tenerlo così che io non però...Comunque io lo faccio anche quando
leggo con i libri digitali tipo, perché
poi mi sto abbioccando quindi mi cade tipo
svariate volte - I libri digitali sarebbe il kindle? - Non
volevo fare la pubblicità - Ma perché io adoro il kindle
- Vabbè allora comprate il kindle...che ne so! - Ero convinta di poter passare sotto i
tabelloni con scritto il nome della
stazione, dato che sono bassa senza
piegarmi e quindi morale della favola: ho dato una testata allucinante contro un cartellone
perché sono bassa ma non così tanto basta - Tu hai preso il palo dal fondo di Via
delle Valli con i roller blade? - Non ho
preso il palo - Tipo hai fatto una cosa del genere?
- Ho fatto una cosa pazzesca!
Va bene parliamone, grazie. Vi ringrazio
per questa opportunità. Io lì mi sono salvato la vita in maniera
epica. Periodo tipo roller brade... - "Robbel Blabe". Oggi va benissimo! - Vabbè stavo con i roller
blade...con i roller brad, capito un tipo di pane. Alla fine di questo ponte c'è
una discesa, una discesa che io non
ricordavo. La discesa non era un problema
il problema era che questa... - L'enorme incrocio che c'è dopo questa discesa - No, prima di questa discesa
c'è una specie di scalino, quindi io vedo
che c'è lo scalino e dico "Porca t****a"
L'unica cosa che posso fare è farmi male, quindi tanto vale saltare. Salto e
riatterro in piedi pazzesco, acquistando
sempre più velocità e davanti a me c'è un
incrocio con delle macchine ed è stato
lì che io mi sono lanciato e abbracciato
- Ah l'avevi abbracciato non l'avevi preso in faccia? - No non l'ho preso in faccia. Potevo prendere in realtà una
macchina - Ed oggi avevamo un bellissimo aneddoto e molti video in meno - Esatto - Ho dato un calcio al bidet
per imitare una mossa di Sailor Moon e per questo motivo mi sono rotto due dita del piede
- Per imitare una mossa di Sailor Moon che è "Bidet di luna"
- La famosa puntata di Sailor Moon contro i bidet...Sailor Moon francese
*francese improvvisato male*
Siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata, io ringrazio Vega per essersi
prestata - Sempre piena di emozioni - E
soprattutto piena di parole che non
mi uscivano, quindi ti ringrazio per
avermi fatto un pochino da correttore
automatico. Ringrazio anche voi che avete mandato i
messaggi, che avete seguito questo video.
Fatemi sapere quali sono stati i modi
assurdi in cui vi siete fatti male ma
soprattutto quelli più stupidi in
assoluto. Se vi è piaciuto questo video
iscrivetevi a questo canale, attivate la
campanellina delle notifiche per non
perdervi altri video. Guarda che in questa parte
mi è ritornato...mi è ritornato l'italiano. Regalatemi un dizionario
e che dire, ci vediamo il prossimo
giovedì - Che dire - Che dire - Che ve lo diciamo a fa
-  Ci vediamo il prossimo giovedì sempre alle 14 con un
nuovo episodio di Vita Buttata. Ciao ciao